They get workman's comp wasn't me. That was patching.
[inaudible] Patrick,
Patrick Mo Rooney and Sean Terry they're a, well, we met,
they're just they're New York firefighters firefighters. You know,
they may or may not be based off guys that from my hometown, right.
Basically what happens is, is, is, is when you go deep into Brooklyn,
when you meet a guy like Patrick Mulrooney and Sean, Terry, what? Just,
things are a little bit more clear. It's an easier life.
And what I mean by that is when you go in there, first of all, it's,
it's very Republican and you just understand things like you understand the lies
from the media. You understand that? Yes, of course.
Climate change was from the Chinese 100%. It's like,
tell me it's 80 degrees out. Why is it cold today? Why is it,
why did I call today?
And I'll tell you why it's because the Chinese makes it hard and the Jews
control it.
it's just going to bury me this thing I heard of the Jews control it.
We're fine. We can edit it out. Did we come out too hard?
I think he came out swinging too much. Yeah. Okay. All right.
Let's show me on the back. Yeah. Let's scale it back. Um,
how did you get into comedy? Should we just do the whole,
should we do scoot a hole, a pocket issue on Terry and Patty Murray.
We can't do it. Let's just go like that show. Where are you from?
Are you from Los Angeles? How many? There's a, that's a real town. Sure. Yeah.
The whole place is on fire. Cause Jesus don't like that place. Yeah,
because yeah. Yeah, you vote to the left. Your place goes on fire.
And that's what God says. That's what it is. Well, who's Sean. Who's Patrick.
That's the problem, Patrick Melrose obviously. Now switch now.
Let's see what it sounds like when you I'm sure Terry. Hi, I'm Patrick.
Mulrooney I'm in the closet. [inaudible] yeah, no.
I'm it's way to impress my friends, but deep down,
how many of those tough guys are actually gay, but won't come out. Uh,
most of them, right? Yeah. I mean, I got a friend who's like,
he's a classic firefighter. I mean, he comes with me on trips.
He'll ask me three weeks before what he's supposed to wear. What should I wear?
Send me pictures of his jeans and his shoes does this match. I'm like guy,
if your friends ever knew,
if your firefighters ever knew that you were sending me these pictures,
maybe they're all wouldn't want to be.
They wouldn't want you to be behind them in a fire. You know what I mean?
Get the hose. But they're all doing that.
They're in that house alone all the time. Think about that. What are they doing?
Watching TV the whole time. Yeah. It's like, what are you? My girlfriend?
You don't think they kiss each other at night a little bit before they go have a
good firefight before they get on the truck. You have a good firefighter. Yeah,
because it is often like that, but it's a soft tap could live in the firefight.
So it's not gainless you've got a perfectly manicured beard. Why, why?
I want to feel it from the inside. It's nothing wrong with that.
Nothing wrong with that. What do you mean you,
you guys are both perfectly manicured manners. No, no, no.
That's like a nice beer dude while I'm trying, you know,
I knew Gingy when he came to New York, I have to do this kind of, yeah.
I have to look like this. You know where he's from? Chicago, Chicago,
Chicago, Illinois. It's the same kind of guy.
We got those guys in Chicago as well. But their Mo you know,
their whole thing is all about homos. They don't like homos. Yeah. I don't know.
Moses. They call them Mose. They're just not my kind of guys. Oh, I bet.
They're nice guys. I don't want them anywhere near me. You know, I, they're not,
our homeless is going at a trend. I want to go to the Trek. Or did he,
same as gaze is homeless. The same as kilos. Most they call them most.
We call them Democrats. I call them Democrats.
That's my name from Hillary support character piece.
Last show me the emails out of 14th character like Chicago.